somebody was wilding out with Nick
Cannon you know it has been so cool to
watch Nick grow up in Hollywood and he
gave me a tour of his new offices where
we talked about everything from his new
gig all them babies and daughter
Monroe's viral moment it's another E.T
exclusive
[Music]
I just saw the tick tock you saw her
daughter how was that did you see her I
loved it to me that was epic my daughter
the entertainment bug is bitter is she a
singer yes really but you know like like
her Mariah they doing they they doing
what they do like that's all so I don't
even know if I'm allowed to talk about
it right that's because Mariah was like
let me handle this I got you she got it
nothing but love for Mimi but the viral
Tick Tock also features Nick's other ex
Kim K it was shocking at first and I was
like but then it was also built to be
like all right I see what y'all doing
it's just not going viral remember when
they dated back in 2006 cut to now
Nick's a busy dad to a dozen kids how do
you figure that out the timing to spend
with everybody everybody thinks it's
time management it's Energy Management
as long as we're all on the same page
and we all got the same goal to be the
best parents we could possibly be that
works and then the scheduling is the
schedule that's the secret I just gave
y'all the secret another parenting
secret Nick keeps his 12 kiddos close at
work I got got an exclusive tour of his
sprawling incredible office space where
he runs his estimated 20 million dollar
Empire next to his own personal room
just a nursery how many kids can you get
in there about 12.
so this is the bullpen area this is kind
of where you know we just get creative
yeah okay about to uh show me up the
fact that we trying to do an interview
and play ping pong come on come on come
on this right here is this is my DJ set
up wait a minute wait a minute he's got
a barber shop I mean not that I would
need it now but I'm just saying this
room the Sugar Factory baby oh yeah I
know I'm a big kid and I love candy what
you want to talk about
a room yeah come on this is our gaming
arcade and we we have fun in here every
single day I'm popping from one room to
another with a different job how many
jobs you got nick uh about as many as
kids
well now Nick's building up the Next
Generation taking 10 Rising performers
on his 24 City future Superstar tour
starting tomorrow in La so what does it
take to be a future Superstar you got to
have that Superstar energy it's already
within you it comes from within now I
can bring it to the Forefront and get
the opportunity uh to show myself as a
businessman and a music executive would
you ever put one of your kids on the
tour if daddy's there yeah are you done
God decides when we're done I got my
hands full and I'm so focused I'm locked
in so you know as of right now but you
know when I'm 85 you never know I'm like
foreign